at times perhaps without quite knowing
why we slip into a resolutely lazy mood
we're simply not able to write anything
new or can't face setting up more
meetings we don't want to clean the
fridge or go out to befriend prospective
clients or we have an appetite for it
seems is too long on the sofa and maybe
dip randomly into a book wander down to
the shops and buy a packet of biscuits
or spend an hour or so soaking in the
bath we might at an extreme merely want
to sit by the window and stare at the
clouds for a long time in such states of
mind we're rapidly liable to be
stigmatized as profoundly and
incorrigibly lazy by friends or more
painfully by our own conscience laziness
feels like a sin against the bustling
activity of modernity it seems to borrow
us from living successfully or from
thinking in any way well of ourselves
but to consider matter from another
perspective it might be that at points
the real threat to our happiness and
self-development lies not in our failure
to be busy but in the very opposite
scenario in our inability to be lazy
enough outwardly idling doesn't have to
mean that we're neglecting to be
fruitful it may look to the world as if
we're accomplishing nothing at all but
below the surface a lot may be going on
that's both important and in its own way
very difficult when we're busy with
routines and administration we're
focused on those elements that sit at
the front of our minds we're executing
plans rather than reflecting on their
value and ultimate purpose but it's to
the deeper less accessible zones of our
inner lives that we have to turn in
order to understand the foundations of
our problems and arrive at decisions and
conclusions that can govern our overall
path yet these only emerge shyly and
tentatively when we're feeling brave
enough to distance ourselves from
immediate demands when we can stare at
clouds and do so-called nothing all
afternoon while in fact wrestling with
some of our most prefer
dilemmas we need to distinguish between
emotional and practical hard work
someone who looks extremely active whose
diary is filled from morning till night
who's always running to answer messages
and meet clients may appear the opposite
of lazy but secretly there may be a lot
of avoidance going on beneath the
outward frenzy busy people can evade a
different order of undertaking they are
practically a hive of activity yet they
don't get around to working out their
real feelings they constantly delay the
investigation of their own lives they're
lazy when it comes to understanding
particular emotions their busyness may
be a subtle but powerful form of
distraction our minds are in general a
great deal ready to execute than to
reflect they can be rendered deeply
uncomfortable by so-called large
questions what am I really trying to do
what do I actually enjoy Who am I trying
to please by contrast the easy bit can
be the running around than never pausing
to ask why they're repeatedly ensuring
that there isn't a moment to have doubts
or feel sad or searching busyness can
mask a vicious form of laziness our
lives might be a lot more balanced if we
learn to reallocate prestige pulling it
away from those with a full diary and
towards those wise enough to allow for
some afternoons of reflection we should
think that there's courage not just in
traveling the world but also in daring
to sit at home with one's thoughts for a
while risking encounters with certain
anxiety inducing or melancholy but also
highly necessary ideas without the
shield of busyness we might bump into
the realization that our relationship
has reached an impasse that our work no
longer answers to any higher purpose or
that we feel furious with a family
member who subtly exploiting our
patience the heroically hard worker
isn't necessarily the one in the
business lounge of the International
Airport it might be the person gazing
without expression out of the window and
occasionally writing down one or two
ideas on a pad of paper the point of so
doing nothing is to clean up our inner
lives there is so much that happens to
us every day so many excitements regrets
suggestions and emotions that we should
if we're living consciously spend at
least an hour a day processing most of
us manage at best a few minutes and
thereby let the marrow of life escapists
we do so not because we're forgetful or
bad but because our societies protect us
from our responsibilities to ourselves
through their cult of activity we're
granted every excuse not to undertake
the truly difficult labor of leading
more conscious more searching and more
intensely felt lives so the next time we
feel extremely lazy we should imagine
that perhaps a deep part of us is
preparing to give birth to some big
thoughts as with a pregnancy there's no
point hurrying the process we need to
lie still and let certain ideas just
state sure that they may eventually
prove their worth
we may need to risk being accused of
gross laziness in order one day to put
in motion projects and initiatives we
can feel properly proud of
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life click
now to learn more